restoring the Northern Ireland Assembly
has been a political imperative for
Prime Minister Boris Johnson not least
because his brexit plans need a
functioning government here at Stormont
so the PM came to Belfast keen to talk
up the opportunities presented by the
new power sharing deal we work with this
revived government in Northern Ireland
to ensure that we deliver on that
potential but away from Stormont for
three years of political paralysis have
left Northern Ireland's public sector in
crisis there is considerable public
cynicism about political promises we
have holes in the roof
we have leaks everywhere the floors are
splitting apart Malone
integrated College is a remarkable
school a beacon of integration between
Catholic and Protestant communities but
it's buildings are falling to pieces and
the symptoms of underfunding are all
around it will take more than just
political will to reverse the years of
neglect here everything is just falling
apart falling apart and it's all
destroyed and it's very very dangerous
for these kids and it's just you make
doing land and we have Mia doing had to
meet doom and over the last number of
years but nobody should have to work or
be educated in a system like this is not
fair it's not fair on these kids they
deserve that on this in July of last
year a parliamentary committee back in
London conceded that Northern Ireland's
education system was facing unmanageable
pressures that stagnant funding was
having a devastating impact and that the
problems had mounted to the point where
they had become a crisis and that is the
situation now demanding an urgent
resolution from Stormont in December
Northern Ireland's nurses began strike
action in protest at a health system at
breaking point nurses here are paid
$1,800 less than their counterparts on
the UK mainland nearly three thousand
vacancies remain unfilled hospital and
cancer treatment waiting lists are the
worst in the UK the power sharing deal
offers renewed hope but nursing unions
want to see the colour of the money and
if nurses do not have a formal
commitment made to them by the Health
Minister
this week it needs to be done this week
we will be back right on to picket lines
again on Monday Wednesday and Thursday
of next week because nurses have been
need many many promises those promises
now make the converted into action
it's estimated that Northern Ireland
needs 2.6 billion dollars to address the
various crises and there is serious
concern that the government's won't say
whether they'll fund that amount this
power-sharing deal in itself may not
mean a quick end to the public sector
storm Paul Brennan al Jazeera Belfast